i know we were talking to ronnie earlier
about how upset i am and that he's
moving to vegas
but he told that jason or one of them
that he pumped one out real hard with
stephanie thursday night and it was
intense
exactly i said to the guys what does
that mean and i was wondering if ronnie
could just
tell me what that means yes what
happened i was out
you know i was outside working all day
you know throwing stuff out of the house
and then i got really like horny
for some reason it seems like whenever i
do like
like like major physical work i get all
charged up for some reason like that
well you got horny too because you got a
young girlfriend who you know and she's
always walking around naked right
when it's time to go to bed yeah but not
before that she
lately she's been wearing these like old
old lady [ __ ]
outfits around the house sounds like it
sounds like stephanie's retiring too
yeah you want to ask me oh my goodness
stephanie
hey what's doing how are you am i really
supposed to just look good for him all
the time
you know like sometimes after like a 12
hour shift and
and it's just been non-stop on my feet
all day
literally just want my sweatpants and
you know in a good hoodie
and and wrap up under a blanket and lay
down and watch some tv with them until
we have
ronnie ronnie told me um when he was
packing he he
behind your back throw out your
sweatpants so that they won't make it to
vegas
you know what he's thrown out so much
[ __ ] i would not be surprised if he
threw out
he tried to throw away um one of the
chargers for
for one of my deltos and i was like what
the [ __ ] you doing like i actually
need that stuff right what could is a
dildo without a charger
and by the way it's not like ronnie
dresses hot for you why should you have
to dress hot for ronnie you know
exactly so what happened ronnie's
describing thursday night
that he got lightheaded [ __ ] you he
was so intense what what is he talking
about
um and he's been going nonstop for
almost a week since tuesday we got a
huge ass dumpster delivered
right and we're just throwing [ __ ] away
and of course the days that i'm not here
he's just going and going and dumping
stuff
so it's just it's been a lot on him and
then of course
he gets his urge and yeah but ronnie
said hey ron
you said you almost blacked out when you
were [ __ ] stephanie uh
thursday night what was going on yeah uh
i i don't know i actually i i don't know
what happened
it was kind of crazy it was like it was
like
this big explosion and i felt like i was
gonna pass out
wow wow wow well if you're going to die
that's the way it is
because like when like i felt like like
fell off her
after afterwards oh my goodness and it
was just like
laying there like breathing my brains
out remember that
yeah it's like you took everything out
on that yeah like everything it was like
all my frustration came out inside her
she almost killed you yeah
that you fell off her well i was
like i was on top of her and then i like
felt like collapsed and like just
like rolled over to the side wow
like a dead body wouldn't you like to go
that way ronnie
yeah definitely no reason why i
shouldn't